bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan i j
piccola premessa prima di cominciare se
sentite con la voce strana più strana
rispetto al solito e perché sono
raffreddato il naso chiuso
io mi sembra di parlare tipo un robot mi
sento optimus prime in questo momento
però va beh voi non so se sentite la
voce diversa ma se è diversa perché sono
raffreddato quindi scusatemi
oggi è sabato dovrebbe esserci happy
wheels o su motori dreams soltanto che
ho voluto fare anti chamber che questo
videogame qui perché ha ricevuto tanti
di quei premi che michael titanic ma
presi così tanti tipo miglior indie del
2011 2012 non ho capito neanch'io bene
comunque ricevuti troppi e non sono
anche bene di che cosa si tratta quindi
andiamo a giocarlo
allora c'è mi posso anno questo non è un
e noi e penso fosse un menu e prigioni
socievoli softchoice the first of kings
giorni wow che è successo ok bene cos'è
sta roba
all you need to know
no che figo ma questo sarebbe tipo menu
aspettate ma tipo no che figata assurda
e va beh non sto a cambiare i settaggi
sennò mi si impappina tutto il video
però vabbè cos'è sta roba the new man in
27 minuti york reuters i sei ed
automatica li ha praticamente un gioco
bisogna finirla entro un'ora e mezza io
sto perdendo tempo tranquillamente ok
muoviamoci cos'è sta roba
exit sinistra a destra quando ci posso
andare perché una vetrata ok cioccio 0
destination clickair ok jump ok
presumo che io debba saltare allora ci
prova raga rincorsa losacco dio dove
cazzo ciò è accaduto
ok io pensavo che miri trasportasse
ritel e trasportasse ce l'ho fatta a
dirlo dietro da dove ero saltato ma
evidentemente no
ok qua c'è una pecora che cade file
ictus assad does not mince ferring
progress
ok ragazzi anche adottivi da qualche
parte a casa ma noi proseguiamo c'è una
strada illuminata però ne vede un'altra
ne vedo un'altra e noi andiamo di qua
tra l'altro anche i colori visto gioco
sono talmente e vivaci che veramente
sono felicissimo che cazzo di posto è
dove sono ok
bene c'è un addio cos'è e dopo o di una
porta lan e la porta al grandi portal
ragazzi come la prendo la voglia voglio
voglio voglio lo voglio
la voglio bene non so come prenderla ma
andiamo avanti andiamo avanti di di qua
c'è una strada perfetto boh io mi sto
facendo domande qua ci sono due vie
paradiso inferno
ovviamente inferno vanno in crederete
mai che io figurati se faccio le cose
facili bene accesi maybe e e simples
going left organ great una scelta può
essere migliore può essere più semplice
che andare a sinistra a destra e andiamo
a sinistra continuiamo a scendere
fantastico continuiamo tranquillamente a
scendere odio ancora ma quante cazzo di
sky ci sono ma mi state prendendo in
giro ancora ma basta ceva minchia ma
posso passare tutto e commentari a fare
andare ad azioni sopra [ __ ]
andiamo lì sopra [ __ ] scala di sotto
probabilmente di sotto dei czars doesn't
matter hotels.com in the same
ok io non sto capendo ma va bene che
continuiamo ma basta fatemi fare
qualcosa continuando a salire e scendere
non sa ma bastano quanti cast ci sono
[Musica]
ma vaffan se ciao vabbè dai che cazzo ma
mi nonna non ha senso cioè non sa cos'è
sta roba vicino devo fare tipo james
bond adesso c'è mi abbasso come siccome
ci si abbassa e odio cos'è a non è un
laser
io penso mit lanciasse tipo metà invece
si è aperta la porta bene ok click esche
o che devo cliccare esche clicchiamo
oddio cos'è ma siamo tornati all'inizio
ha già if i don't like where your hand
dap trading something else ok va bene
c'è acqua c'è odio si è sbloccata si è
sbloccata la destinazione che prima non
c'era
bene ma posso a figo quindi posti che
che trovo praticamente meli me li salva
hanno una vocalità sta cosa
la jump to form a come faccio ad
arrivare laggiù c'è impossibile
devo per la mente saltare un key che
figo ma io come ama forse devo camminare
no ma che figata si crea pavimento dio
non avevo capito cosa questo muro levati
dar cazzo televi bene c'è un muro che
non posso a girarlo perfetto sì sì sì sì
o tutto ok c'è un coniglio 8 per sé
proprio in can change e abilità in cui
set va bene io non ho idea di che cos'è
questo un occhio l'occhio di sauron
oddio oddio
se ti porto l'anello mi fai passare se
ok no di masi cosi oddio si
smaterializza al ponte vado sul ponte
appena appare vado vado sul no no no no
no cazzo sono caduto
ran into a propria volta il wave de roi
du risolto va bene allora chi è capo dio
oddio sono caduto il pavimento mi ha
mangiato spacebar ci sono i tasti della
tastiera raga io non so cosa siamo di
nuovo qui c'è ma stavolta si apre
soltanto se io guardo allora scusatemi
io faccio così via
ok dopo da cosa cos'è sta roba sailing
for words ok ma che cazzo è sta roba
veramente madonna mi fa piacere
oddio c'era un corridoio prima c'era
l'ho visto l'ho visto il corridoio nomi
fottete non mi fotte the c'era prima e
sull opa prima era rossa non era verde
bene noi andiamo di qua
raga non nostro adesso adesso è
disputato il corridoio anno non c'è si
vede solo lì attraverso ben yozma devo
smetterla di farmi domande perché non ho
capito che cazzo est europa
ok io smetto di farmi domande perché non
capiscono trento intanto lascia la porta
gun ma vabbè è comunque non capisco che
cazzo sta succedendo noi andiamo avanti
c'è mi sembra che sia dentro il
televisore adesso mi sto rincoglionendo
raga andare avanti
vabbè ciò il cervello raga che mi sta
picchiando il cranio mi sta continuando
a dire basta smettila è veramente e
stressante giocare a sta roba mi sento
come se stessi comando un bongo comunque
noi di qua ci sono già passato ma prima
non c'era la freccia beh son progressi e
vado di qui vado vado di qua qua c'è la
porta a gun qua io mi ricordo di esserci
già passato però sta porta non me la
ricordo
oddio siamo tornati al menu bene però
siamo nella porta che prima non c'era
cioè che prima era non c'era la vetrata
life is it about getting to the end si è
magari e mo e ma che cazzo succede
ok c'è un
ci sono dei due portali o non ha
soltanto uno sul soffitto e o c'è un
vetro come cazzo ci passo cioè sta roba
ovviamente
non facciamo domande andiamo avanti
perché veramente io non ci sto uscendo
pazzo dove minchia sono vai a sinistra
si a sinistra c'è la porta al gun di
nuovo però non posso arrivarci come al
solito
e allora dove vado vado di qua
l'unica strada ma senza se non c'è un
altro di sti cosi c'è la porta il gal
raga forse riesco raggiunge ma che cazzo
è successo ma ero lì prima ero li
privano l'assenza come ho fatto entrare
vabbè allora raga sto per prendere il
portal gun o la porta anzi la porta via
vai
ok l'ho presa che cosa dovrebbe fare
adesso grandi portali tipo in portal
quacosa e lupin sarda in half men and
you will get to where we want to be che
cosa oddio se aperta la porta bene cosa
vi serve sta roba non spiegate
agira bello bello e utile in discoteca
per ora volendo poi portarla e fare tipo
che cazzo è successo come mai adesso c'è
un cubo ho preso
ho preso io ho preso un cubo che stava a
bloccare la porta che figo e ma volendo
posso di bloccarla perché ci devo
passare lì
c'è una ragazza una mira di merda ok
perfetto
solo che troppo ha magari lo blocco
piace anche se c'era chi è scritto di
bloccarlo più in alto per ora che io mi
conoscete lo so che lo sapete che non ci
arrivo aste cosa inutile che che fate
quella faccia come dire che [ __ ] lo
sapete che lo sono vabbè comunque
andiamo avanti sia aperta la porta
perfetto però si è richiusa mi sta
crollando e bene come cazzo fate mi
sarebbe di nuovo il cubo perfetto però
come come minchia la metto se se la
porta si chiude non faccio neanche in
tempo a meno che non riesca a metterla
non posso metterlo attraverso il vetro
quindi come cazzo faccio ma forse
aspetta un attimo
non so se funziona ma si funziona che
genia ok sándor sub il close al essawi
hold'em open alcune porte si chiudono
finché non le lasciamo aperte ma che
cazzo vuol dire
sto cupolo prendo grazie si è chiusa la
porta dietro forse intendeva questo la
frase non lo so ma andiamo avanti
perfetto c'è un atto cubo ok
it's hard to progressi fior living
things behind bene allora dammi il cubo
subito però se lo prendo si chiude la
porta e come nicchia dovrei fare bene ma
ho fatto ho fatto anche il fallo che il
gatto tasto sbagliato per mettere il
cubo da non importa ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta ci vuole veramente un
bambino di due anni per risolvere gli
enigmi però per me è già tanto e va bene
prendiamo il cubo però una porta è
rimasta al aspettate un attimo così
rimane aperta quella dentro hanno capito
ho capito ho capito
vai così ok ha però che si rimane
l'ultima chiusa e come cazzo faccio a
meno che non forse no non facciamo sì
però
sì sì
ok innanzitutto mi riprendo il cubo qui
perché devo ammetterlo da qualche parte
qui penso qualcosa c'è scritto there are
molti provvisto approccia situation ci
sono più vie per approcciarsi alla
situazione allora come mi devo
approcciare me lo dici tu perché io non
ho capito nulla di quello che ho fatto
finora ma non importa c'è
ok a si è aperta la porta ok perfetto
bene bene già stiamo facendo è un gioco
troppo nigma tic ora che cos'è questo è
un trampolino è un trampolino cos'è bene
soltanto che non mi permette di andare
tanto il giù perché c'è il soffitto che
rompe i [ __ ] ma non importa vabbè
andiamo avanti
cos'è questo un ascensore perfetto che
siamo
c'è un buco sul soffitto don't look da
un
cioè se tu vuoi che io non guardi di
sotto devi dirmi guarda pure perché se
no io è la prima cosa che faccio
beh a buongiorno divo lei che dio no
oddio no no no no no sto cadendo su
accadendo perfetto
mi spiace caro con una sottiletta sono
ancora vivo
ho sentito un tuono ma sono ancora vivo
evidentemente ciò possono fatto di gomma
o tipo sono un gatto too much curiosity
can get the best of us troppa curiosità
può tirare fuori il meglio di noi è
quello parla per te perché io non sono
tanto curioso questo si è addormentato
sul sul piatto eh va beh meglio i truck
button del sound way is up
ok siamo qui ma di nuovo ma se io faccio
così [ __ ] a pupa non son caduto e
allora adesso che cazzo devo fare mi
butto lo stesso oppure torni indietro
non penso che però c'è un'altra storia a
noi c'era un'altra strada indietro per
come prima
però è un miracolo che io ci sia ma
questi sotto ti cubi a bello è un
miracolo che ci sia arrivato comunque
ragazzo hurdles che non so che devo dire
hurdles non sono anche se si pronuncia
così heart alive tour over jump over
sì questo l'avevo intuito infatti c'è un
miliardi sono miliardo di qb apposta
credo perfetto
ebbene sì o forse no
oddio che cosa è successo
dove cazzo sono finito ok veramente
volevo portare sicuri dove dovevano
metterne tre però sono caduto da qualche
parte evidentemente vabbè non facciamo
quota fra quota fa che lo dico io
ceva oddio che cazzo succede sono caduto
di nuovo c'è ma io sto visto gioco
continua a cadere
c'è una roba assurda e tutta una caduta
cuocerà houdini cos'è cose che appaiono
impossibili magari hanno una risposta
semplice questo di la tua sorella perché
finora non ho avuto un cazzo di semplice
andiamo di qualche prima non ci sono
andato qualcuno tatto questa questa roba
qui dice life
però non ho capito bene il sen oddio
cos'è una sedia un asse col cazzo è
pieno di di roba oddio mamma mia
ma cosa una galleria d'arte minchia
regno di d3 è mia e tu a soreta e non so
che caso o di un cubo prendiamolo non si
può prendere sto gioco dalla odio così
fa questa questa una galera è una
galleria d'arte epica c'è veramente ma
chi ha fatto sto gioco è un genio di
cos'è questo
cioè no raga l'audio che sentite di
sottofondo è semplicemente mi stanno
chiamando su skype
quindi spero che finisca presto ok basta
è rotto il cazzo non rispondo non
rispondo non posso sto giocando a danti
chambily si sta incamminando il cervello
non sono dell'umore adatto per
rispondere ok perfetto bene ha smesso di
chiamare fortunatamente comunque questo
un telescopio va ora ma cos'è cos'è
questo no ma è una figata sembra tipo il
metal gear smontato comunque nord a
queste ping pong fa io ci passerei cost
ma veramente laga questo gioco più
artistico che abbia mai visto guardate
che figo no ed ai na figata queste cose
sono una figata mi piace un casino
abello fantastico beh cos'è questo bene
beh questo è il pensatore questa la
conoscevo in teoria dovrebbe essere
messo così
una cosa molto seria però evidentemente
non ha la faccia tipo slider andiamo
avanti
c'è un orologio ok fantastico questo non
mi chiedete che cos'è
e poi c'è c'è tutta roba strana
fantastico comunque veramente epico
qua invece l'unica roba in cui non c'è
nulla ashton entrato dentro si può
entrare dentro sono io l'opera d'arte
vabbè comunque a parte gli scherzi
dovrebbe essere un tunnel meglio
absorbers tranding su you may notice
notize things that you dinsey before
mamma mia che inglese mi faccio
veramente ribrezzo ad ascoltarmi quando
parlo in inglese
ok sì c'è una strada inutile di nuovo
non so sono tornati indietro
ok sto tornando sto continuando a
tornare indietro non è che come prima
che devo tirarmi tipo e andare avanti
ok perfetto era così
ormai non mi fotte mi avete potuto due
volte non mi potete più
no dio è ok l'opera finito di dirlo mi
avete riflettuto raga io per sé cose qua
non ci capisco allora il mio cervello
penso che sia non lo so e d'amore che mi
sta tipo trapanando dicendo basta
smettila
ce l'ho fatta ah beh meno male
if you never stopped rainews il get
there eventuali ok destra sinistra
andiamo a sinistra ok decidiamo a caso
no ma era comunque veramente io non ci
ho trovato un senso finora cos'è questo
size can leave a trani in grande in
circles ok alcune scelte possono
smettere di farci girare in tondo
io giro in tondo vanta mi pare no vabbè
ragazza mi viene da vomitare
io non so cosa devo fare ma veramente
chiudo qui l'episodio perché se no posso
continuare tutto tutto il tempo a girare
in tondo anzi anzi adesso chiudo al
video mentre continua a girare in tondo
e vabbè
continuerò il prossimo episodio perché è
veramente strano oddio ci ho fatto ciò
fatta cioè fatta
non so come ma ce l'ho fatta e sono
tornato indietro assistenza è l'unica
opzione bene io alcune frasi non riesco
a tradurre e piuttosto che tradurle male
preferisco non farlo qua c'è una freccia
che indica a destra di nuovo sul ponte
di sauron
e vabbè se salve mi fa passare gli rigo
l'anello di nuovo il perfetto
e vabbè da io mi fermo qua ci vediamo al
prossimo episodio ditemi se vi piace e
soprattutto se c'è qualcosa che ho
saltato prima perché ho saltato un
casino di enigmi perché ovviamente lo
scopo di questo gioco è passare in tutte
le zone per poi riuscire ad uscire per
poi riuscire ad uscire si dice è una
cosa bruttissima da dire però non
importa se qualcuno di voi sa riuscito a
capire un qualcosa di che ho fatto
precedentemente che ho saltato me lo
dica e di che mi soprattutto se vi piace
se volete che lo continui lo farò più
avanti
nell'episodio niente dire che posso
finire qua come al solito seguito vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che come al
solito trovate in ogni mio video nella
descrizione niente se non siete iscritti
iscrivetevi ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazzi